MANO MARKS: OK.
Hi.
I am Mano Marks.
I am a developer advocate
on the Google Maps team.
This is Sean Maday.
SEAN MADAY: I'm Sean Maday.
I'm a geoengineer on the
Enterprise team.
MANO MARKS: So it is
our pleasure to
do the session today.
We're really happy to see you
and everybody on live stream.
Hi.
So I want to talk a little
bit of history here.
And some of you may have gone
to the session yesterday--
What's New in Google Maps.
And Brian McClendon talked
a little bit
about where we started.
And this is the first
Google Maps.
This is Google Maps
Beta in 2006.
And we started out with points
and driving directions.
And it was a really
revolutionary
interface at the time.
At the time, if you wanted a
map, you had to go to a map
image, and if you wanted to zoom
or pan, you had to click
and load a whole other image.
There probably would
be a little
iframe that would refresh.
It would be like 10 seconds,
because this was the
internet back then.
And what Google did was it
looked at that and thought,
wouldn't it be fantastic if we
could do a better experience--
a nicer, smoother experience
that would not require this
sort of disengagement
from the user.
And so we released what has now
become a very standard way
to do maps online.
Google started this tile serving
infrastructure using a
JavaScript interface, which
allows you to dynamically move
and pan your maps and add things
to it without having
these huge lag times--
an exploration of the
map, of the world.
And we incorporated map tiles
and satellite imagery all
around the world.
And it became this
it sensation.
So much so that people, within
days of seeing this, had
reverse-engineered it and told
us, hey look, we can do really
amazing, cool things.
And so in 2006, we actually
released the Google Maps API,
version 1, and asked developers
to come with us on
this journey--
this journey of exploration of
the world, of geospatially
organizing the world's
information.
And they did.
You did.
If you're in this room, you
probably have written a Maps
API application.
If you are a web developer, you
have probably written a
Google Maps API application.
There are 800,000 active
websites--
that's active websites--
using the Google Maps
API right now.
800,000, and it continues to
grow at a really huge rate.
So in 2006, we asked you to
do this journey with us.
And now you have.
And we are now asking
you to do it again.
Because, as Brian talked about
yesterday, there are still
dragons at the edges
of the map--
referencing old European maps,
which used to say, here be
dragons at the outskirts
of your map where
they didn't have data.
So we want you to join
us on this journey
to get rid of dragons--
this adventure to get
rid of dragons.
He actually called it
dragon slaying.
We're going to slay
some dragons.
So we want you to join us.
And we want you to do
it the way we do it.
We want to make our
infrastructure available to
you to serve out maps in the
way that we did it--
learning the lessons that we
have of creating a really
incredibly developed
infrastructure for
serving out maps data.
And we want you to be able
to do the same for your
organization.
So please, this is--
they always tell you to do a
call to action in these.
I'm gonna do the call
to action early.
The call to action is join
us in this adventure.
OK, so let's talk about
what that means.
That means we want you to build
your maps in our cloud.
We want you to reach users
on every platform
that you can reach.
And we want you to integrate
our data with your data in
your applications.
Three basic key takeaways.
If you don't remember anything
else, you'll remember.
If you're watching on the live
stream, you should still watch
the rest of it, but those
are the key takeaways.
OK.
Let's talk about what
that actually means.
This right here is a Maps
API application.
You may say it looks like a
fairly standard Maps API
application.
I didn't gussy it up, because
I'm not really a designer.
But think about it this way.
Even if you were the state of
Louisiana, or not literally
the state of Louisiana--
but you are a representative
of the state of Louisiana.
You're concerned about the
impact of oil natural gas
infrastructure on disaster
preparedness.
So you want to visualize
where things are.
So we actually went
out and did this.
Sean found a great site provided
by the state--
right, the state
of Louisiana--
that had data about
where things were.
And we put that on this
Maps API application.
So here are the Haynesville
shale wells.
Here are some oil
and gas fields.
Here our some permit points for
new permits for drilling,
I'm guessing, and polygons
that impact the
areas where these are.
Here are some levees.
You get you get the
idea, right?
We have lots of interesting data
about where things are.
Well, here's the trick.
So you've probably
seen Maps API
applications like this before.
But all this data is actually
being served off of Google's
infrastructure.
This is all data that's living
in Google Maps Engine and is
being served directly to
a Maps API application.
The only thing that
is not on Google's
infrastructure is the sample.
This is an HTML5 slide deck.
I have an HTML page and some
JavaScript just sitting on my
laptop-- but it could be
on a server somewhere--
and that's it.
All the data is served directly
from our servers in a
highly optimized fashion.
And I can share that data
with whoever I want.
I've made this public, because
I'm making a demonstration,
but I could limit access
to who can do
what with this data.
So think about this
as an example.
Sean's going to walk you through
a little bit more, but
first I want to talk
to you about what
the cloud looks like.
Why should you think about
our geospatial cloud?
Google Maps is used a million
hours every day.
For a million hours, people are
using our infrastructure.
The billion monthly active
users of Google
Maps services and--
I don't know, how many of you
know about Santa Tracker, seen
Santa Tracker?
All right.
You guys are part of the 1.6
million queries per second
that our infrastructure handled
on Christmas Day when
some very brave data center
engineers stayed during
Christmas Day, probably fairly
alone in the data centers,
making sure that Santa Tracker
stayed up and running--
1.6 million queries
per second.
So we have a solid
infrastructure that we've
developed that will help you
serve your data when you need
it-- and during the lean times,
when you don't have
very many users, and during
the high peak periods.
That's what you should
be thinking about.
But there's more.
We have available for
your use the world's
largest imagery database--
20 petabytes of imagery.
That's just the data that we
make available through maps.
We have constantly updating
base data.
So the maps are being updated
moment to moment.
We have people in Map Maker.
We have a project called Ground
Truth, where we're
actually sourcing our own
data and inputting it.
And we also have additional
data providers.
So we have a massive
amount of base data
constantly being updated.
We provide you with access
control, rock
solid access control.
So if you're familiar with--
how many of you use
Google Docs?
And Gmail?
All right.
It's Google I/O, that's not
a fair question, right?
But you know then, about
access control.
You can make a document
public.
You can make it private.
You can make it unlisted.
And we give you additional
access control, but it's based
on the same solid
infrastructure--
so security and stability.
And we have API integration.
We have the world's most
popular web API--
the Google Maps API.
I'm not kidding when I say
probably everybody in this
room and everybody watching
has done a Google Maps API
application.
I'm sure somebody's going to
tweet me later or plus me
later, and be like, I haven't.
But statistically speaking,
almost all web developers,
anybody who's done JavaScript--
lots of people
learn JavaScript by actually
developing Maps API
applications.
It's simple and powerful--
huge amount of features, huge
amount of services.
So that's why you should
be trusting our cloud.
Now Sean is going to talk
to you about the
details of Maps Engine.
SEAN MADAY: All right.
Thank you, Mano.
As Mano described to you, we at
Google have gotten really
good at this geospatial stuff.
Consumers around the world trust
our two-dimensional maps
and our three-dimensional Google
Earth environment to
make fast informed decisions.
It's that familiarity that we
look to leverage with Google
Maps Engine
I should ask how many of you
have used Google Maps Engine
or put your hands on this
product to this point.
Good, OK.
So for those joining us via live
stream, the thousands of
people in the audience all
raised their hands, and their
applause and laughter and
cheer was actually a bit
disruptive.
But we're back now.
Google Maps Engine is how we
have basically productized the
processes and the pipelines
that we used to make the
platform behind Google Earth
and Google Maps.
So we have really awesome
engineers, outstanding
infrastructure that does lots
of really cool things with
geospatial data.
Specifically, our core
competency has become
simplifying the delivery of
complex geospatial data.
And that's what we're offering
with Google Maps Engine.
Google Maps Engine allows you to
take your imagery, terrain,
and vector data, upload it
into Google's cloud.
It's replicated in
our data centers.
We handle the redundancy.
We handle the failover.
You then are given tens of
thousands of processing nodes
to do interesting things to
process your data and to style
your data, and then all sorts
of interesting end points to
deliver your data out to your
intended audience, whether
that audience is public or
whether you just want to share
your data with certain
individuals or groups.
And we'll talk through more
of this as we go.
But these end points include
Google Earth, Google Maps, the
Google Maps API, OGC Standards
like WMS, as well as some
mobile end points we'll display
for you on a zoom
tablet here in a little while.
So in the last six months, we've
really opened up the
Google Maps Engine platform and
brought in some trusted
testers and some early
customers to use this platform.
And as Dylan Lorimer mentioned
to you yesterday, we're now
going to increase the velocity
by which we bring
stakeholders in.
And we're hoping to bring lots
more individuals and
organizations into
this ecosystem.
But today, it's interesting to
note that this platform is
already hosting 165 terabytes
of imagery.
Our vector data store is
composed of over 2.5 billion
features at this point.
And that's growing
exponentially.
And today, Google Maps Engine
is being used to serve over
1,000 published maps.
So small numbers by Google
standards, but really some
impressive usage and some
impressive adoption in just
these first few months.
So as I present to you today,
what I want to do is show you
the Google Maps Engine
interface.
I want to get you familiar with
some of the workflows.
Specifically, I want to show
you how to upload data, how
that data is aggregated into
individual layers, how you can
style those layers, and then how
you can publish a map to
many of those different end
points that I discussed
previously.
So as I operate and show you the
interface, we're going to
be referencing back to the
Louisiana Oil & Gas demo that
Mano showed you earlier
in the presentation.
And my goal today is to show
you the workflow around two
different types of data--
that is imagery data, or raster
data, and vector data.
In regards to vector, I'm
going to show you three
different subsets, points,
lines, and polygons; how these
are handled inside of Google
Maps Engine; and what tools we
give you to style and deliver
this data out to your users.
So Mano showed you what we have
as far as our base data
around Louisiana.
As we zoom in here, I'll then
activate some of the layers
that he presented to
you a bit earlier.
Specifically we can look at
some point data, like the
permit locations.
We can look at polygon data,
i.e. the polygons that
encompass those permitted
areas.
We can also look at line
data, like the levees.
And then, if our map weren't
cluttered enough, we would go
ahead and add some
raster data.
So here's a topographical
chart--
really interesting way to
visualize topographical data,
in this case, that was
housed by the USGS.
And also imagery-- so I grabbed
this quad of ortho
imagery here from USGS.
We can throw that on top.
This is a scene that Google
doesn't have in our imagery
database, but this is available
to the public
through USGS.
And what I really want to
highlight here is that the
Google Maps Engine platform is a
really unique way to deliver
all this data to the end user
in a simplified way.
Any user who's familiar with
Google Maps zooming, panning,
interrogating icons by clicking
on them, will be
familiar with this workflow.
And the engineering we've done
in the background makes this
delivery fast and efficient.
So the user's not sitting
around waiting for
this data to render.
MANO MARKS: Sean,
one key point--
where does this iframe
come from?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, great
point there, Mano.
So this iframe is actually being
populated right now by a
Maps widget, which is another
end point that we have within
Google Maps Engine I'll
show you a bit later.
But this is a little
bit of embed code
that we provide you.
So at the very simplest
implementation, you can put
one line of HTML code into your
organization's website or
into the public facing website
that you want to use to
support a disaster response or
humanitarian relief-type
situation, and have all of this
Maps interaction inside
of inside of your
web environment.
So one other thing I want to
touch on before I jump into
the live interface demo is this
concept of zoom levels.
Zoom levels are the way that
we handle the delivery of
tiles inside of the Google
Maps environment.
So if you're delivering a map,
you have a couple options.
One is to produce a really large
map, high resolution,
and that can be difficult
to interact with, right?
The other option is to give
you a small image that has
very low resolution.
What Google Maps API and Google
Maps has done is they
use a tiling schema, so that
when your zoomed way out
looking at the whole world,
we're just delivering you a
couple tiles that represent the
world in low resolution.
And as you zoom in, you're
seeing more tiles, each tile
smaller, and those
tiles represent
higher resolution areas.
The reason this is important is
because on the Google Maps
environment that we provide on
consumer devices and to the
average public, we have a vector
team that's done a
phenomenal job of making sure
that the right attributes are
visible at the right
zoom levels.
So for instance, when I'm zoomed
out and looking at the
United States here, I'm not
seeing every secondary and
tertiary street that's
available.
In this case, at this zoom
level, it may be appropriate
for me not to see any
streets at all--
maybe just the labels associated
with states.
As I zoom in further
here, I start to
see interstate highways.
As I zoom in further yet, I'll
start to see smaller
municipalities and smaller
infrastructure pieces.
This is all important, because
in Google Maps Engine we give
you the tools to style your
own data and to decide how
that data should be presented
to your audience.
And this chart is handy only in
that, as we style some of
this data in the demo next, I
just want you to keep in mind
that when you see these zoom
levels, this is what we're
talking about.
Zoom level 5, we're talking
about being zoomed way out at
a global view.
Zoom level 17, 18 to 24, we're
talking about being zoomed way
in where you could see a
building or a street.
And without further ado then, we
will step off and show you
Google Maps Engine.
So this is the landing page of
the dashboard that currently
exists for Google Maps Engine.
The first thing you'll notice is
that inside this dashboard,
I have some analytics--
so some basic metrics on how
many of my layers are being
consumed, and when my peak
usage is happening.
I can also do some querying
based on time to really
identify when my map data
is being consumed.
The basic building blocks inside
of Google Maps Engine
are data, layers, and maps.
Data is the raw source
information and the raw source
files that you might currently
have in your geospatial
repository.
Those are aggregated up into
layers and styled in layers
inside of Google Maps Engine.
And then layers are brought
together as maps.
An example of a map would be the
Louisiana Oil & Gas demo
we just showed.
So the first piece here
is data ingest.
So what I'll show you here is
how we would upload a piece of
source data.
The upload interface
is fairly simple.
It's just going to ask me right
off the bat if I'm going
to upload imagery
or vector data.
For this demo, I'm just going
to show you what it would be
like to upload some imagery.
This is always the dangerous
part of the presentation
though, because I'm going to
browse to a piece of imagery,
and if I do this wrong, I'm
going to end up in a folder
that has all of my Justin Bieber
images and you will
forever taunt me.
So we have to make sure we land
in the right place here.
Here, for example, is one
of those USGS quads.
It's a .tif file.
Google Maps Engine will consume
geoTIFFs, JPEG 2000s,
MrSID, most of the industry
standard raster formats.
In addition to that core source
piece of data, we will
also take side car files, like
world files and projection
files that might provide
amplifying metadata associated
with that image or
that vector data.
So in this case, I don't want to
just include the TIFF, I'm
going to include the world file
and maybe even one of the
attribute files that's
associated with it.
From here, I have the ability
to name that layer.
It's going to default to
whatever the file was named,
but I could put in anything
here that made sense to my
individual project.
I can then decide who I
initially want to share these
layers with.
The relevance and the importance
of this sharing is
really the inside of the
Google Maps ecosystem.
You can have many map makers.
Map makers are those who can
style data and compose maps
based on layers.
So in this case, I can decide
which group or which
individuals inside of my
organization I want to share
this layer with.
And then I can assign
attribution.
Attribution is a catalog
of source information--
source provider information--
that you cultivate and you
populate inside of your Google
Maps Engine environment.
It allows you to very quickly
add attribution to your Google
Earth or Google Maps
end point.
You can put in the
date acquired.
This is very handy if you're
going to do some
temporal-based positioning or
if you're going to show
historic imagery or
historic raster.
This is very important, because
you can leverage this
in a few different ways.
You can throw in
a description--
and then, tags are very
significant, because tags are
what allow us to actually make
this data discoverable and
searchable inside of our
Google Maps Engine
implementation.
So I'm actually going to cancel
that and show you what
this looks like once it's
already uploaded--
save you the excitement
of watching that
upload dialogue progress.
But what I can do now is I can
search for some of this data.
So up in the search bar
here, I'm going
to search for Louisiana.
Here's all of the layers that
I have branded with that
Louisiana keyword tag.
Here is the raster layer
I was just showing you.
This has been uploaded
and processed.
Google Maps Engine is extremely
fast at processing
and has gotten faster even
in the last six months.
So it can do really
wild things with
large chunks of data.
The raw size for
this particular
image was 110 megabytes.
But now we can deliver those
out as small consumable map
tiles for the end user.
We get some information
on the resolution.
In this case, we see this
piece was 2.4 meters per
pixel, which equates
to a zoom level 16.
So back to our pyramid--
this would be good to
about zoom level 16.
And from here, I can
then aggregate
this data into a layer.
So if I do another search of my
layers now to show you what
my Louisiana data looks like, I
can show you all the layers
that I have built using
this Louisiana data.
Specifically, I want to show you
some of the point data we
talked about earlier.
In this case, it's the oil
and gas locations.
It's the oil and gas wells.
One thing you'll notice is I get
this thumbnail preview in
the upper right hand corner,
which shows me the geographic
parameters of this
particular file.
Interesting to note here that
this layer of Louisiana Oil &
Gas actually shows me that I
have coverage all the way up
the center of the United
States through
the Mississippi corridor.
What we can look and
QC, quality check,
here with the preview--
and we'll let this render
here a second--
but what we can see is that the
quality of this input data
wasn't great.
And in fact, this Louisiana Oil
& Gas data will show me a
couple wells that are located
in northern Minnesota.
So the point I want to make
there is that this is not a
tool right now for editing and
for curating your core
geospatial data.
And you want to make sure that
the data you upload has been
quality checked before you bring
it into this ecosystem.
Let's see if I can actually--
there's the actual-- there's
our delinquent well there
way up in Minnesota
that throwing us off.
So the point being there that,
again, we're not here to
replace your existing desktop
GIS-based systems.
The systems you use to generate
and cultivate this
data are important.
We're just going to become the
visualization layer that
allows you to easily share this
information with your users.
From here, I can edit
this layer.
And this is where I wanted
to show you zoom levels.
So I have basic options here
to assign either some point
icons, some place marker icons,
or do some different
stylization on these
individual points.
Interesting to note there that,
right now, we don't
support custom icons, but
that's coming very soon.
And what I really want to hit
home with that is that there's
some really rapid development
cycles
inside of this ecosystem.
And the benefit of a cloud-based
environment like
this is that we are on a very
fast release cycle where we're
pushing these things out
every few weeks.
And your users and your map
makers will be able to take
advantage of this functionality
without
installing the latest software,
without going
through an IT change
management process.
One of the benefits of the cloud
is, as fast as we can
roll out these new features,
they're going to be available
to you and your map makers.
From here then, I can decide
when these individual well
attributes should be available
at which zoom level.
I can also set up some dynamic
filters based on the
attributes inside of
that source data.
So maybe if you're zoomed way
out, I want to show you large
wells-- wells that have a
certain production value that
is quantified inside of
the attribute table.
In that case, I can set up some
pretty simple greater
than-, less than-, equal to-type
equations here to
really specify what portions
of the data I want to be
available at each layer.
I can dynamically cascade those
filters down and really
create a customized view
for my end users.
The same basic workflow exists
for line and polygon data.
I'll show you that just with
levees, again to hit home that
this is all very customizable.
In this case, we could decide
what colors we want the levy
to be, full color palette
to choose from.
We could decide how we want
to style those lines.
We can also decide how we
want to present labels.
And again, using the cascading
filtering, we could decide
that maybe we want labels on at
a certain viewpoint, but we
want the labels to drop off and
become invisible once the
user is drilled into a
certain zoom level.
All of that's customizable
inside the Google Maps Engine
vector-based styling UI.
Finally, these layers are all
aggregated inside of maps.
We'll let this load here.
And what I want to specifically
show you and what
I can search-- there we go--
is what these maps look like.
So here's my Louisiana
Oil & Gas map.
It's going to show me all the
layers that I have aggregated
inside of this map.
It's going to give me some
metadata about when it was
processed, when it
was published.
And this is where I can really
set some granular sharing
parameters.
So very much like the sharing
parameters inside of Google
Docs, if you've used those, I
can decide which other groups
inside my organization I
want to be able to edit
and modify this map.
And then I can decide how I want
to handle the viewing--
the Map user side--
of this particular data.
I can decide to share
this layer publicly.
I can decide to share this layer
with just a specific set
of groups or individuals.
And then finally, here is
my gateway and all those
endpoints we talked
about earlier.
So this is the URL I could click
on to interact with this
map in a Google Maps
API environment.
The Maps widget that Mano
asked about earlier, the
iframe code, this is all I would
need to paste into my
web server in order to bring
this Google Maps environment
inside of my website.
And then also we have
a WMS link here.
The benefit with WMS is that now
we can consume this raster
and vector data inside of our
traditional desktop GIS systems.
So for instance, if I have a
cadre of QGIS users or ArcMap
users, this one environment can
serve the geospatial needs
of my entire organization and
any partner organizations I
might bring into my ecosystem
on an ad hoc basis.
Specifically there, I'm thinking
about disaster
response or humanitarian relief,
where you have private
organizations partnering with
public organizations in very
dynamic relief efforts that are
then over a month or two
months later.
And that's the power inside
of Google Maps Engine.
It's that you can very quickly
share access to your data
without giving up that source
data, without having to move
around gigabytes or megabytes
of source data.
You can share visibility and
just as quickly revoke that
visibility.
Mano's going to talk to you a
little bit more about some of
the data behind our Maps
API or some of usage
behind our Maps API.
But this is actually how
I would reference these
individual layers
from Maps API.
That's all detailed for
me here as well.
So the two things I want to
show you before I step off
then, is first the integration
with Google Earth, both in the
client and in the web-based
plug-in.
So I'll switch this over
to Google Earth here.
We'll give it a second.
Maybe.
Possibly.
It wouldn't be a true
demo if something
didn't go wrong, right?
The demo gods are unhappy.
We didn't sacrifice to them
before we started.
MANO MARKS: Oh, sorry.
SEAN MADAY: So that's probably
what happened.
MANO MARKS: Forgot that.
SEAN MADAY: Do you have
Google Earth on here?
Do you mind if I launch it?
MANO MARKS: Do you want to
just open up Google Earth
instead of the plug-in?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah.
MANO MARKS: And show that?
Yeah, I do.
So yeah, just go
down to there.
SEAN MADAY: OK.
So obviously, I lied to you.
This is Mano's computer,
so those Justin Bieber
pictures were his.
I tried to defend him.
MANO MARKS: Train.
I don't know what you're
talking about.
It's Train.
SEAN MADAY: All right.
While Mano tries to fix that,
let me show you what this
looks like from a mobile end
point, which is kind of cool.
Let's see if we can bring
this up here.
All right, so what you're
seeing here, or what you
should see here is
a zoom tablet.
Come on.
Maybe.
Who did we make angry?
All right, I'll give
this one more try.
I swear this worked before the
presentation without any trouble.
MANO MARKS: It did.
SEAN MADAY: All right.
Perfect, thank you.
So here from inside of Google
Earth, I can quickly zoom out.
You'll notice now in the Android
application we have
for Google Earth, you
can authenticate
to Google Maps Engine.
It will then build me a list of
layers that I have access
to based on the username and
password that I use to
authenticate to that
Google Maps Engine.
From there, I can activate the
layer and then decide which of
those layers I might want to
see inside of my mobile
environment on my Android
device, whether
that's a phone or tablet.
If you have the Google Maps
downloaded on your Android
device, I would highly encourage
you to check this
feature out.
It's quite neat.
Here you're seeing all the
layers that I have access to.
I can dynamically turn those
layers on or off and view them
as I see fit from this
mobile device.
Mano's logging into our Google
Earth implementation over here
on the desktop, so
let me switch
back over to his machine.
MANO MARKS: There you see I just
went up to File and Log
In, logged into Maps Engine.
By the way, you may have heard
the old name for Maps Engine,
which was Earth Builder.
We rebranded about a
month or so ago.
And then, you see here I have
all the private maps that I
have access to.
I can also enter in a globe by
address if it's a public map.
So then--
SEAN MADAY: So, similar to
unlisted layers that you may
have seen with implementations
like Fusion Tables.
MANO MARKS: Right.
Exactly.
So then, here I have the
Louisiana Oil & Gas, and I'm
going to click on that and
go back to Google Earth.
And you'll see down here in the
layers section, I actually
have Louisiana Oil & Gas.
And so it's actually integrated
directly with my
experience in Google Earth.
So as I zoom in, you'll see that
I start to see some of
this data showing up--
different zoom levels
that it's set for.
And there you go.
SEAN MADAY: The user can also
control the opacity on this.
So they can very quickly
go from your enterprise
geospatial layers back to
Google's authoritative base
globe information, all within
the Google Earth environment
that they know and love.
One other end point we'll just
discuss before I pass it back
over is Google Earth Portable.
Google Earth Portable is some
really interesting software
that our engineers have
been working on.
It allows you to draw a polygon
around that Google
Maps Engine implementation that
you've created, extract
all the imagery, terrain, and
vector data inside of that
polygon and create a local
cache of either
two-dimensional map data or
three-dimensional Google Earth
data that your users, your field
workers can take with
them out into an austere
environment where they may not
have connectivity back
to Google's cloud.
So that's one of the ways
we're bridging that gap
between ground and cloud.
I appreciate your time, and I'll
pass it over to Mano to
run you through some of
the developer options.
MANO MARKS: And actually, here
is that Earth plug-in that you
were looking at before.
It hadn't loaded up quickly,
but that's because I had
loaded in a new browser.
And it's the first
time, I think, it
was using that cache.
So this is directly loading off
of Google Maps Engine, but
it is using the Google
Earth plug-in.
So it's a 3D environment
within the browser.
And you can actually do this
with your own Earth API
applications as well, which
would allow you to combine
with other sources of
data that aren't
hosted on Maps Engine.
So I'm going to switch
back to the slides.
I turned off my clicker so
I wouldn't bother Sean.
There we go.
So now we're going to talk about
Google Maps Engine for
developers.
There are four different
pieces that you need to
remember about Maps Engine for
developers at this point.
We're in a fairly early stage.
We have MapsDataLayer, which
allows you to take maps and
layers from Google Maps Engine
and apply them directly to
your Maps API applications.
There's a JSON Feed that you
can get, which gives you
access to information
about what is stored
in individual layers.
You can also load a side
database using the Earth API,
which is similar to what
I just showed you.
And then if you need to do
authentication it it's a
private map, you use OAuth.
So we don't have time
to get into the
details of OAuth here.
And frankly, authentication is a
pain, but I'm sure there are
other people here who can
walk you through that.
But just keep that in mind.
So what we're going to be
showing here is public maps,
but this will be--
if you can implement OAuth in
your application, you can
actually get access to
private maps as well.
So let's go back to this demo
that we showed here.
Now this is, just as a
reminder, same data.
It's the same demo we showed
at the beginning.
And there's this USGS chart.
Well, I click on it, and it's
actually really tiny.
It's right down in here.
There's not a whole
lot that's there.
And then there's some
ortho vector data.
We just basically couldn't
find any--
there's some great raster data
at the site where we were
downloading data.
So keep that in mind as
we get back to it.
But this is basically Maps' data
layer loading in that map
that we've been working with.
So here's some basic
code here.
You load in the Google
Maps API loader.
You use the visualization
library.
So if you're not familiar with
libraries in the Google Maps
API, we have a number
of libraries--
one of which is visualization--
that are loaded as extra
parameters to the loader.
That is, if you don't load
them, then the API knows
nothing about them, so it
reduces the size of your code.
And then you create a new maps
data layer object and pass it
map ID, layer ID, and
the map that it's
supposed to create on.
And so these are the
basic pieces.
Remember-- visualization,
maps data layer.
And then what you get back as a
piece of that-- this is what
the JSON object contains,
the information
here about your layer.
And it gives you a lot of
information in there,
including the bounding box for
a particular layer, a list of
all the different layers that
are associated with a
particular map.
And that allows you to do some
processing to figure out how
you want to display and interact
with the data.
And so some of the key stuff on
here is asset IDs and the
keys for the layers.
So what I did in that demo
before is I just used some
jQuery to go through, parse out
each of the layers, and
add a check box with an
event handler that
triggers them on and off.
We're not done yet, but I want
to give you just a little
thing to keep in your mind.
We announce later this year
that we're going to be
releasing a full read-write
API for Maps Engine, which
will allow you to upload your
data programmatically to
Google Maps Engine.
Currently, that's not an option,
but that is something
that we are working on and
believe that we can release
within the year.
And we think that will allow
developers to do a much more
dynamic approach to uploading,
styling, and
implementing data.
OK, but let's talk about a
couple of other features of
our Geospatial Cloud that aren't
specifically tied to
Maps Engine.
And this will all come
together in a minute.
One thing that we released at
Where 2.0 this year is the US
Demographics Layer.
So it's a layer that's available
to Enterprise Maps
customers--
if you have a Google Maps
API for business.
And if you have Maps Engine
you get a business license
along with that.
So it's available for internal
applications.
And you see here that I get data
from the US Census about
things like income, population
density, property values, and
a lot more.
So we're going to take a look
at income in San Francisco.
In 2010, you can see the
different census tracts in
there have different
income levels.
And you can look back.
We actually have the most recent
census information.
We can actually even show you
the boundaries for the census
block, so you get a
nice sense of it.
And then we also recently
released--
actually the first public
announcement of it was yesterday.
Dylan talked in the What's New
in Google Maps API talk about
the Google Maps Gallery,
also called the
Google Earth Gallery.
And in here, you have
lots of maps
that people have created--
KML files, and also Maps Engine
files that people have
uploaded and made public for
anybody to have access to.
So this is real time sharing
of public data.
And you can do this-- if you
have Maps Engine, you can
submit your maps to
the Earth Gallery.
So let's bring those
together, though.
Remember, I mentioned that I was
a little disappointed with
the raster support in the
state of Louisiana site.
That the raster imagery-- we
just didn't have very good
coverage, we felt.
So what we did here is, I pulled
into this Maps API
application a separate
Maps data layer.
And I brought in topographic
maps from the US Geological
Society, USGS.
And you see here, I can see the
actual topographic maps.
I can even see metadata about
these if I'm at a zoom level.
Well, that doesn't show
up right there.
But if I zoom in, you'll see I
get a little metadata about
each individual map.
And I can actually see a
bounding box of the different
portions of that raster.
So these are three layers
provided in a different map, a
public map made public in
the Google Maps Gallery.
And I just loaded it directly
into the Maps API application,
the same one-- or actually,
a slightly
different file, obviously.
And then I added in,
also, demographics.
So I can look in and I can see
at a glance-- this is income
by census tract.
What I can see here is the
impact that, for instance,
permit polygons--
where they are in
relation to the
demographics of that community.
And I can tell, for instance,
the impact that new drilling
might have on low income or high
income, whatever groups
that I'm interested in, those
different communities.
So you can see by bringing these
powerful visualization
technologies together, I can
do some really interesting
visual analysis of my data and
layer in different features
from different maps--
bringing it all together and
then serving it all off of the
Google geospatial
infrastructure.
So this is your next
call to action.
Tomorrow, Sean Wohltman-- the
other Sean, as I like to call
him; actually, when I'm talking
to Sean Wohltman, I
refer to Sean Maday as
the other Sean--
and Mike Evanoff are running a
codelab here where you can
actually play--
Mike's in the back there.
All right, Mike, other Sean.
OK.
This is the other Sean.
Don't worry.
They're going to run a codelab
with a number of tutors-- a
number of people will be there
to help out-- where you can
actually get your hands on Maps
Engine and play with it.
And they're going to walk you
through a lot of these steps,
including, for instance, the
OAuth stuff that I kind of
glossed over because it doesn't
really fit well in my
nice presentation.
But they will cover that in
detail, And you'll actually be
able to get hands on, using
this in a development
environment.
So I'm really excited
that they're here.
And I actually sat through a
couple of their different
practice sessions for it.
It's really going to be great.
So that concludes the
presentation.
We're really happy to have you
here, and happy to see that
there's an interest in it.
After this, we'll be out
in the Sandbox--
at the Google Maps Sandbox--
if you want to ask us
additional questions.
And we can take questions now.
And of course, both of us are on
Google+ and Twitter, so you
can find us there if
you want to ask us
questions out in the--
well, that's not really
the real world, is it?
SEAN MADAY: The real
virtual world.
MANO MARKS: Yes, so thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MANO MARKS: So we can take
questions right now.
If you would, if you want to
have a question, please come
up to one of the two mics
that are provided.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you for
telling us about this new,
exciting product.
I was wondering about how
Google Fusion Tables--
the spatial aspect of that--
fits in with this.
Is this a replacement?
Or do they work together?
Or is Fusion Tables
being deprecated?
MANO MARKS: Fusion Tables is
still an active product.
It's part of Google Docs.
And it does run on Google's
infrastructure.
It's a different kind
of product.
We saw the interest that
was generated by that,
particularly among Maps
developers, and we got excited
about that.
And we learned a lot of
lessons from that.
Because it uses a different
infrastructure for Maps
Engine, we can actually serve a
much greater amount of data.
Do you want to give the stats
on how big a map can be, how
big your files can be?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, what we saw
was that Fusion Tables really
showed that there was a demand
for doing lots of complex
geospatial analysis
in the cloud.
So what we've tried to do with
Maps Engine is provide vector
tools that will handle tens
of millions of vertices or
hundreds of millions
of vertices.
So that's where we're really
focused with Google Maps
Engine, is getting beyond those
small use cases into
those niche geospatial use cases
where there's really fun
things you can do with
big data sets.
MANO MARKS: I spent a lot of
time last year talking about
Fusion Tables.
And when I talk to people who
worked in the geospatial
industry, I would say,
well, you can upload
large amounts of data.
They'd say, really?
How much?
I'd say, well, you can have
files up to 100 megabytes that
you can upload.
And in the geospatial
world, that's not a
large amount of data.
But for a lot of use
cases, that is.
So we think they fit into some
different use cases.
And also we've worked on the
raster support, which isn't
something that we can really
do in Fusion Tables.
So we think this is definitely
the enterprise
solution in the way we--
SEAN MADAY: If you need a
service-level agreement for
tens of millions of vertices,
Google Maps Engine is where
we'd point you.
MANO MARKS: Right.
And how large are the files
that you can upload?
SEAN MADAY: So at this point,
we can support several
gigabyte files.
And we're expecting that limit
to grow exponentially in the
months ahead.
So we've got some really smart
engineers who are doing great
things with our vector store.
And that's going to
get big quick.
MANO MARKS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a simple
question that introduces a
more difficult question.
SEAN MADAY: I'll take
a simple one.
And then I'll pass it to Mano.
MANO MARKS: I'll take
the hard one.
AUDIENCE: The simple
one is about data
visualization rendering.
Do you foresee to have the
possibility to classify data
based on an attribute of that
data, so make dynamic
classification?
And this introduces the second
one, which is how do you plan
to evolve this product?
Will it become a GIS product
in the future?
Thank you.
MANO MARKS: You want
the first one?
SEAN MADAY: Sure.
So, yeah, great question on
classification of data.
Specifically, I assume you're
referring to raster data.
We announced back at the COP
16, the climate summit last
year in Mexico, that we had been
working on a platform we
call Google Earth Engine, which
starts to do some really
neat raster analysis.
We look forward to tighter
integration of that platform
with Google Maps Engine as these
platforms both mature.
But right now the Google Maps
and Google Earth Engine API is
available to trusted testers.
And if you want to start doing
some raster analysis and
classification, it's a really
powerful platform for doing
what you described.
MANO MARKS: Talk to David--
he's in the audience right
there with the hair--
for Earth Engine.
So then the question is does
this become a GIS?
And I guess it depends on
definitions of what is a GIS.
And I've seen lots of
conversations about that,
particularly a few years ago,
it was what is a GIS?
At this point, what we're
looking at is, Maps Engine is
a way to serve and share
your GIS data.
And we are a platform for
collaboration and a platform
for integration.
And we're also a way for you to
reliably have your data in
the cloud in a way that
is not going to fail.
So that's where we're at.
And we're also looking at--
we have this WMS output.
So we're looking at ways in
which you can actually then
use Maps and Engine to integrate
not just with your
web applications but with your
other GIS applications.
We're not done.
We've been out for six months.
We feel like it's a great
product, and it's going to be
really, really fantastic
at some point.
So we're really--
come with us on this voyage.
I think we're going to have
some really special
stuff coming up.
SEAN MADAY: And just to add to
Mano's point, I would really
challenge that this is GIS
revisioned and reimagined.
And our core competency, again,
is simplifying the
delivery of complex
geospatial data.
So my mom, my neighbor, when
they want to understand
geospatially what's happening in
their neighborhood, they're
not going to install a
heavyweight GIS application on
their desktop.
This is the way we see ourselves
as being that
visualization layer that makes
this consumable to everyone.
MANO MARKS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You were talking
about the ability to push
edits using the read-write
APIs.
And I was wondering, have you
decided to allow concurrent
editing between multiple users
that would show up in real
time to all users?
And if so, how do you handle
data collisions?
MANO MARKS: You mean
through the API?
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
MANO MARKS: We haven't released
any details on what
the API's going to look like.
So we've got the basic
infrastructure for developing
the API, but we haven't figured
out all the details,
and I don't want to promise to
something that we can't--
SEAN MADAY: More to
come on that.
All right, any other
questions?
MANO MARKS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You haven't been
mentioning routing.
Are there any plans for
adding new routing
features in Maps Engine?
MANO MARKS: That's
a good question.
So you mean routing over
your own data?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MANO MARKS: That's a really good
question, and it's the
kind of thing that
comes up a lot.
And the only thing that we have
announced right now about
future features is that we will
have this read-write API.
We can't tell you what other
features until Dylan Lorimer
tells us that we can.
We can't tell you what other
features are going
to be part of it.
But it's a really
good question.
I talk to developers around
the world who are really
interested in that kind
of functionality.
It's very hard to do.
And we actually have solved
it on our own systems.
I'd love to be able to
give that to you.
SEAN MADAY: And I would
recommend, too, stop by the
Sandbox and see what some of
our partners are doing with
this platform and all
of our geoplatforms.
MANO MARKS: GeoEye, I think,
is there today.
GeoEye provides much of our
satellite imagery today.
And they use Maps Engine as a
way to work with partners and
distribute their data.
It's really great and
inspiring to hear
what they're doing.
Other questions?
OK.
Do you mind getting
to the mic?
AUDIENCE: You presented the
styling for the points.
Do you have the same for
polygons, points, lines?
Is it going to be a whole
theming tool?
SEAN MADAY: We do, yeah.
So your question was on, if I
heard you right, styling for
points, lines, and polygons.
Just in the interest of time, I
left off after I showed the
styling of lines.
But yeah, styling of polygons
is in the tool today.
And we only expect that those
styling features are going to
become more robust in
the releases ahead.
So I'll slowly bring that up
as we're talking here.
But yes, the answer to your
question is yes, we
support that now.
So here's the permanent
polygons.
I have the ability to edit these
styles with both what
the border should look like,
thickness, color, and then the
fill, with not just a color,
but an opacity as well.
AUDIENCE: Once the API is out,
would you be able to do that
through the API?
SEAN MADAY: Our goal is to
provide a rich set of features
through the API.
So, there are no specific
announcements, but absolutely.
MANO MARKS: If you see Dylan
Lorimer, ask him.
Get him a couple drinks, and
maybe he'll tell you.
SEAN MADAY: Tell
you everything.
MANO MARKS: Any more
questions?
OK, great.
Thank you so much.
Again, we'll be out
in the Sandbox.
SEAN MADAY: Thanks, everyone.